what's up guys welcome to another
gamespot plays it is I tie with the
lovely Mike McCarty attack what's up
Mike how's it going let's play some
uncharted sweet we're gonna play the in
charter Nathan Drake collection well
actually Mike's gonna play it right
because um he's young and has like those
twitch reflexes I guess so you don't
want me playing this game no not at all
no so we are fortunate enough to be able
to do a quick preview a subjective
preview of all three games and we
thought it'd be fun to run through a
chapter of each one so we'll start with
the uncharted drake's fortune and just
kind of work our way we should just
continue from the plane wreck why not
yeah we'll skip the intro yeah ty was
playing this a little bit i actually we
were both playing us a little bit
yesterday but yes i got to a certain
point in the story so yeah I just wanted
to I wanted to show off obviously the
game is running a full 1080p now 60
frames per second which is awesome and I
was playing this yesterday and it just
kind of brought back a lot of memories
of what 2007 was when this first game
this game came out so that's probably
announced in 2006 yeah 83 and then it's
awesome another cool thing is we can
hopefully we'll be able to show you
these some of the differences between
this version and the original this is
the sense of the first game in the
franchise the visuals are a little bit
different obviously it performs
different but yeah this is great though
and this is after he thinks we should
also preface this by saying we're gonna
spoil some [ __ ] so the statue of
limitations on this game is way past
yeah so if you don't want to be spoiled
just turn this video off and don't
[ __ ] [ __ ] about it in the comments
I'm tired of this [ __ ] I don't know my
this is after Sully you find the u-boat
this is where after you find the u-boat
slowly gets shot you think he's dead
Drake shows no remorse whatsoever no he
seemed surprised and then moves on with
Elena Fisher to the island where he
thinks El Dorado is yeah where he thinks
the the Germans may be moved or the
Spanish moved El Dorado so right there
was a German u-boat earlier on there was
a you go yeah and he found the map there
and then the the creepy I forgot the
guys name the creek
dude it's like in every Indiana Jones
flicks the creepy white guy who wants to
just rain the world who's been faithful
eventually just melt yeah so basically
he he's the one they supposedly killed
Sully there we go yeah it's kind of like
Assassin's Creed esque par core stuff
this is like the same remember the
sixaxis controller on those things like
you would have to balance it i want to
i'm still have to do that you're going
to come summer pirates the first of many
a murderous pirate rampage here the one
thing i liked the one thing that
bothered me about this game is the fact
of the pickup ammunition like you do
right now you still happen to do that
unfortunately but the cool thing about
this version is that the trigger the
shooting now is with our too yeah not
our one which is fantastic r1 reloads
now but does okay it's Alaska I'm close
to dying oh there's always a risk I'm in
the head good job so uh ma'am when this
game came out it was like no no it
doesn't make you do any more thank God
rustic no I am I light a and when this
game came out of his interesting because
you kind of thought that I don't know at
the time you thought not a dog wasn't
impossibly doing a jak and daxter yeah
and then maybes came out the whole new
IP and then they really tested the
limits of that cell processor on that
ps3 yeah this was kind of that
transition between the charm of Jack
indexer and then just the utter like
despair of the last of us yeah because
the last of us was what huh the 2013 oh
and your aim is off there bro yeah uh
yeah well it was it was weird because I
remember when this came out everyone was
calling it like you know there was a
like dude Raider you know like
everyone's like oh it's like Tomb Raider
dude yep and a quick whip you know
Nathan Fillion type you know sarcasm
crap like that and but it was actually
it was just a really fun game in its own
right and obviously people did draw off
comparison to the tomb raider at a time
but you kind of have less puzzle-solving
here even though there is puzzle solving
in this game yeah they really push that
with two I remember their defeat spots
in two or actually sort of got stuck
when I first played too complicated but
yeah
I guess just more so than this game
later we get to a certain point maybe
after this chapter will show you a quick
comparison of a cutscene in uncharted in
this one versus what it look like on the
ps3 there are some minor differences
really it's about performance I think
and I beacon preface this by saying also
there's a day one patch for this game
that that I might have on this stand the
Handy chic here which will hopefully
improve it says here minor fixes for
stability audio and visual improvements
as well as performance optimizations so
you're reviewing this game right for
game spawn yep he would be will be up on
September 30th the game itself releases
on october ninth yeah so yeah the
reviews going up a while before and that
was the worst grenade toss ever I say
that now i'll probably do something yeah
i just want to let people know like
there will review the game but we're not
you're not going to get a full-fledged
comparison only because the game is can
have a day one patch apparently that
will improve visuals yeah so we'll have
to check that out it's weird that
they're doing that on day one so it kind
of makes reviewing the game challenging
but just pass all those aks oh yeah fire
there's all the good fun platformer
still feels pretty good for being the
first game obviously you get those
bigger set pieces and two and three
especially the you know the famous train
scene right at the beginning of to the
cargo airplane and three where you're
just tumbling out kind of doing some
sort of Legolas think another's treasure
get the get the treasures the
collectibles get all 61 of these games
for if not I remember this would this
would like unlock like if you got all of
them and we start to unlock things like
invincibility and what weird [ __ ] like
that i remember back in the day I just
never collected them all I never really
cared to be honest with you oh no I
don't think I did either unless I was
like worried about trophies which I
don't think I was no I wasn't either I
really it's one of those games where I
just quick i loved it for the story
mm-hmm this is the very first game I got
for my ps3 I didn't get a ps3 until two
thousand eight
and I remember this is the very first
thing I picked up for it I actually cut
the video review for this game fri GN oh
nice I remembered Oh Shh whoo I remember
when this first one came out obviously
people are stopped throwing those people
are excited about it because it was you
know naughty dog but took people a while
to realize like how good it took like a
lot of people who didn't play right away
a while you know it's kind of word of
mouth and then everybody like wow this
is actually really good well it was it
was interesting because they you
probably got behind you and a couple of
days I just remember the the the best
thing about this game was the fact that
you're gonna get your ass killed again
Oh blindfire no I like the fact that it
was like in this very open colorful
environment like they even talk about
that when they were developing this like
how to make these like lucious
environments you see the shadows you see
the textures I mean the game the game
still looked great for a ps3 title
especially and I think like I could be
wrong but it seems like naughty dog was
like the first developer they really
took advantage of like the technology
behind the ps3 I remember hearing like
stories like how they like basically how
to rewrite all their code like they had
like their own version of stuff they
operated on when they before the ps3
came out and then for this particular
game they finally kind of just said ok
we're going to redo everything I think
even like maybe nine months into the
production cycle of this game things
went kind of nuts and they just said
okay [ __ ] it we're just going to go full
c plus plus whatever at that point and
they did a good job I may be like you
get in the water and like he's wet you
know like yes ps3 so I'm right yeah I
remember like Killzone 2 looks great on
the ps3 but this was definitely one of
them that really showcases I mean as you
go through that like a lot of jungle
environments in this one that's kind of
biome you're going through the whole
time than a two year in the Himalayas a
lot with snow and everything and then
freeze just maybe desert yeah what kind
of gather festival and I guess might
want to probably cut it too soon if I
don't get a checkpoint yeah let's um I
guess what we can do real quick is we
can show you the in cutscene to this I
already have it okay um go ahead and
roll it Eric I just wanted to show I
wanted to quickly show like some of the
major differences between you
keep playing we'll roll it roll it down
ready anyway so it's rolling right now
as you see right here up top yeah well
I'm just gonna yeah get so this was this
is after he gets captured by one of his
uh I guess competing treasure hunters
and I just wanted to quickly show like
some of the the graphics differences
like you can see on his face on the left
hand side is basically your ps4 on the
right is ps3 so essentially you have a
little bit more textures on the brick
you have more textures and quality on
Nathan Drake again nothing's final in
this particular scene but we just kind
of want to show it off to see how it was
this was actually one of the also cut
seems they released as a promotional
material that guy's what is it what's
his name llego I completely forgot know
a lot about the first game I don't
remember yeah to I I played three a
couple times to I played twice 10 this
is Eddie ok Eddie ok yeah so Eddie
captures them and then Elena prophecy
breaks him free here but this is cool
like this is I think this was the scene
that that really just kind of got me
pumped about this game I was like wow
there's like actually something kind of
fun interesting the story as well really
what drove me to these uh tall thrilling
yeah definitely it's just being able to
go back then there's still the old think
about remastered is just because they
look better doesn't mean they're gonna
be great they could be ugly old games
that don't hold up as well but you know
these games all are still really fun to
play also it's important like I mean in
this particular comparison here the
footage on the ride is through ps3 that
was also captured a 720p we add a wee i
had to upscale it because it's just the
game didn't run natively 1080p it rain
like a 720p 30 you know or maybe did run
a 60 I forgot but regardless like it you
know you can see some minor differences
here obviously if you hadn't like side
by side to become a more like star
comparison yeah but you can tell the
textures the models are a little bit
different and yeah they're just talking
[ __ ] to each other here when Elena is
going to bust him out with the Jeep
eventually at some point we let's roll
to get to queued up so we can start this
do a new game here neither of us have
played this yet you know in the so
there's the brutal yep I have to unlock
it that's how hard it is this game gets
hard on the crushing difficult i
remember i'm not like when you platen in
this thing it was like just the nerve
wracking no and I was like [ __ ] that
done because there's that one scene and
I say scene like it's a movie but
they're very cinematic but they're
you're in the Himalayan village it gets
attacked with like a tank and everything
I've ever that being tough yeah sure I
like how every every game starts like a
quote from some like world Explorer yeah
the third one is uh versus nate is a sir
francis drake than Marco Polo third one
is G own of Arc it is whoever said like
no Lawrence of Arabia except like beware
the dreamers of the day or something
this one the way this starts the way
this game starts is pretty unbelievable
and I like the fact that it's all like
at a sequence mm-hmm it's kind of a
Tarantino thing yeah
you see his outfit change a little bit
he's not wearing like the Henley with
the undershirt mm-hmm things jeans are a
little slimmer in this one yeah he lost
weight don't worry bell-bottoms anymore
no this is a Warren Chuck so you know
he's more like mountain dewd hiking
shoes like that yeah I just member what
a way to start the game yeah so this is
after again spoilers this is after he
meets Chloe right like this whole
because I the game in yeah chronological
chronological order he's talking with
Chloe who's the hot australian girl that
he liked ends up banging at some point
in this game think so and then
everyone's like what would happen to
Elena like it's all about Elena right
let's I remember this was one of those
games really on res like oh I'm supposed
to be controlling this right now yeah
can I other side there we go yeah and
then it cuts back to this yeah this is
probably my favorite one I think yeah I
think it's you know well most people
would say two is the best one i think
i'm looking forward to replaying i'm
just to see how much I still agree with
that here we go um oh geez oh my you're
ok everybody got it don't worry about
how much does I'm being able to dodge
know that actually that was one thing I
was always impressed about Nathan Drake
is that uh he has impeccable climbing
abilities I mean it's just unbelievable
like a guy that never trained as a
climber just kind of I mean in addition
to being a lethal with a gun and
hand-to-hand combat he's pretty handy in
his hands Jackie's a jack-of-all-trades
he's great and yeah it's the scale of
this to start off a games is really
ambitious but they don't really let up
throughout the entire game know some
lulz but it's like a full-on action
movie they I remember the controls being
a little bit tighter in this one too
yeah
it's just like what a way to start a
game and he's also like has no blood
left in his body snow so he's just super
human he's great all right it's just a
cool scene I just remember the scene
being like I'd love to see this side by
side now with the with the original yeah
cuz this looks awesome right now it
looks great the lighting the reflection
on the metal right that looks great yeah
I mean deed I would definitely encourage
people that haven't played these games
to play them because they are a lot of
fun I don't think like they don't I
don't think they do anything like
revolutionary in terms of gameplay like
it's just there's some fun moments the
games look great it was more of an
accomplishment on the ps3 hardware but
at the same time it was just you know
they're just really fun games plus the
writing is just awesome the dialogue and
characters are great well that was one
thing that they took advantage of I
think I think naughty dog really wanted
to capture like human emotion and like
storytelling and they were able to do
that with you know obviously they had
emily rose and nolan north as Lena
Fisher nathan drake and they were able
to kind of really capture their emotions
and their characters like the emotion
capturing everything else and like you
just get some you just get some really
great storytelling moments in this based
off not just a dialogue but how it comes
off you can see in the characters yeah
that's great especially the third one
with him and Sully which is like really
that was probably one my favorite
stories to show like how they be kind of
became to be like buddies yeah because
he kind of raised him yeah well as they
were in the museum I forget where what
country yeah morocco maybe I can't
remember it he's looking through that's
when I first started talking about being
a descendant of Nathan Drake era Francis
Drake yeah
right here is awesome
ja goo see that's like very Hollywood
right yep just so Hollywood havin it
still looks great though it still looks
fun go much better start in the first
here we go three cuz it's three start
leg three the one-step piece i remember
is the cargo airplane your kind of
climbing up the crates as they fall out
yes it's a weird button sequence 3 yeah
I really like three a lot 3 is good
there is one of my I mean it's I think
story-wise that's one of my favorite
ones I think I just liked the whole
presentation of two yeah yeah but this
is where like it this is where like
they're they start like in that pub
right in like London it's Sully in
Nathan and drank and then they get into
some [ __ ] huge ass fist fighting this
is where we're like you start seeming
like a lot of those combos and like you
know Michaela attacks I'm interested how
the remaster will look because I
remember the fighting in the original
game was actually kind of Clippy it
wouldn't be I feel that great so I'm
interested to see if they remedied that
with this which I'm you know hopefully
they did because the shooting feels
great in that never used to it does the
recent enjoy quote at this one
interesting did you see a quote I didn't
see one now maybe they'll do it after
that she's here Nathan talking to London
so they're in London the dreamers of oh
here we go Thank You Lawrence of Arabia
but they may act their dream with 00 he
says it to to make it possible this
you're right no te learns TE Lawrence
Lawrence of Arabia okay so they start in
London and this is where they're meeting
that dude Talbot the raindrops it looks
good yeah yeah they're all dressed up I
saw there like in civilian clothing mmm
please dinner jacket just chillin the
nice british pub there are dinner
jackets and there are dinner jackets
this is the nice i like the transition
from
and hold of the dartboard yep they
really do a good job of making these
like cinematic like I just I love it's
like you are playing the movie it's just
really really cool you just you know
when they walk in I'm just gonna stand
out like [ __ ] tomorrow yeah the guy
in the hood he's not happy nope they all
just want to fight them always want to
take a show a lot of boxers on the walls
yeah you know yeah this guy's gonna
start some [ __ ] this the cuffs are on
their way so it's um it's what was her
name a Catherine right Marlowe yes that
sounds very familiar right I just wonder
who the voice actress was advice oh I
have to find out now nice warm welcome
she Rosalyn is woefully you were way off
on that I remember her looking sort of
looks like Judi Dench I Judi Dench are
like Meryl Streep yeah I can't remember
yeah she sounds like one of them and
then at this is cool because I want to
hopefully we can get through this and
then I mean we probably won't even play
the game we can just comment on it but
first well no you will give you a fight
here yes God pretty soon forget what
happened but it goes straight from here
to the flashback almost positive it does
don't brawl first there's all your money
there's the Queen's so his moustache is
sick Judi Dench's on English bills right
I really know yeah I'm like what I don't
think so no about I need pounds we have
to ask are you gives away his necklace
with that ring sylvan 16th century this
is not tell big guy to think right yeah
he's kind of a douche bag as well drinks
moto well remember there's one point
where him and Marlo are kind of if I may
the twist comes out and then he draped
starts hallucinating they shooting with
that stuff that's right then it becomes
this trip in the desert and then you is
that another thing one like you just had
a hold forward for like a long last time
in the desert what is going on this is
the part I hate about this game that was
the only part to not like about it I
think they tried to do something like
the ladder and Metal Gear Solid 3 where
you just like be patient it's gonna be
impactful but then you're just walking
in the desert for like five minutes yeah
oh you also do that through like towns
remember like you're going through a
town and you're also like walking
through that town and it's taking
forever yeah you canna strain the
cinematic stuff you blew it come on mate
let's get the hell out of here you're
not really in a position to negotiate
now give me the classic shits about the
Briggs and go down gentlemen why are you
still in stripes versus like Jason
Statham come up into st. hey just chill
bro chill that guy is the classic
looking tough English guy don't get
pushed him and he has the classic
looking just doofus yeah bad guy in a
pinstriped suit boom there we go I like
he just walks away comma it's in every
movie the bad guy just starts to walk
away calmly wife [ __ ] and Brett goes
down as long as he has the briefcase I
just member like yeah like you're like
well you're starting on melee attacks on
counter-attack and also they found weed
shed here we go whoo oh and missed that
one there you go [ __ ] about Vegas sorry
no I'm cells you trouble oh this agent
trouble
nice oh no cord is like a big bag yeah
there's your slow mo oh yes this is all
like so Hollywood it's great that shot
was good yeah it's like Oh chapter one
now you either fight more dudes another
round get it works yeah a lot of levels
mm-hmm okay they did a good job like
doing the tutorial like I mean I just I
liked it like it was okay hey yeah
you're gonna do a lot of melee in this
game so here's just a quick tutorial and
it's fun it's like a fun kind of like
Hollywood movie type style scene but
teach you how to decry you all the
counters yeah it's great well there's
Sully get out of selling through a guy
look like its job bro oh yeah just his
face Oh tilefono slow oh now its job
broken in the toilet right yep of course
that's another Hollywood rope yep you
knock a guy out in his face always goes
in the toilet this all seems to love
lettuce le well yeah it is every trope
you could possibly think of let's throw
them all in there more fighting there's
a lot of guys in this bar yeah I got
forgot how much mela you too it's
getting late very beginning of it
bowling is so like it's just what it
just kind of something such a homage to
like all these like movie fight seems to
take place in kitchens using the
environment to [ __ ] guys up and
everything that's great oh here we go
just got a different guy he looks very
similar Oh
Sully's just saw a super time doing
doing what they all look like jason
statham blank oh here's Catherine here
she is he's your duty Dench yeah meryl
streep i think you know what she looks a
lot like her voice actress like wat to
pull her up kind of she does she really
does she looks a lot like her voice I
drove see ya there's a slightly more
malicious than the voice actress yeah
mr. son of and I were in Tommy there's
this weird underlying insanity that she
kind of gives off oh wow cute i forgot
that he shot both of them so did I
cutter shot both of the Mafia we'll get
our revenge don't know yeah I think it's
funny like when you're playing this game
you're like didn't just kill this to you
guys there's no way another heroes the
[ __ ] I'll they died together Sully gets
shot all that well I me not yeah so this
is your class too yeah okay so this is
when they first met he's a kid this I
thought was really cool yeah I thought
this was a one of Columbia by the way ok
so now Morocco like I said different
hemisphere yeah different continent yeah
and he's a little kid I remember all
this now this is great and there you are
young Nathan Drake at the classic 12
years earlier he's kind of dress 20
here's my dress at anything and that is
exactly i wear that shirt sometimes
baseball long slee up i do that my hair
is not quite that long but it could be
he still got the half tuck though yeah
he always doesn't have talked on oh man
it's probably good places to leave it
this week only the pirate I think I
don't want to spoil any of that for the
for the kids yeah i'll give you a quick
glimpse into the room there you go here
we go greatness from small beginnings I
like that and they could play on words
uh yeah so that's the nathan drake
collection coming out when october 9th
October night review a review should be
up on the 30th unless maybe yeah unless
like the patch is really significant but
yeah we have is we have to see what's up
with the patch but yeah and for all your
uncharted needs including uncharted 4 or
nathan drake himself but go to gamespot
com we're getting out of here
you